now thank you for joining us I'm John
langler it keeps getting worse if you or
someone you know is trying to fly on
Southwest Airlines right now boy the
frustration is real today most of the
company's flights have been canceled
across the country Southwest happens to
be the busiest carrier at raid
International we have Team coverage of
what's going on this afternoon at the
Holiday Travel headache Candace Charles
in The Newsroom with some of the
resources for passengers right now but
Ryan Matthey is live at Reed
International with the latest Ryan good
afternoon
yeah good afternoon John it's grown to
thousands of canceled flights leading to
thousands of tired Travelers just here
alone yesterday we saw 360 cancel
flights today it's nearing that 250 Mark
a representative from Southwest just
told me they have 3 000 unclaimed bags
here on property from a vast majority of
the flights being canceled here from the
same airline now the CEO of Southwest
did speak to the Wall Street Journal
recently he told them that they have
canceled two-thirds of the flights they
normally would be operating with for
today and tomorrow here at home nearly
50 percent or about 200 Southwest
flights for tomorrow have already been
canceled 65 flights already canceled for
Thursday we're not seeing as much of the
chaos as we have in the past few days
the early heads up seems to be deterring
flyers from coming on site for now but
people are still sleeping in the airport
struggling to find their baggage and
stuck trying to get home
or they offering you anything nothing
basically they're saying go online and
figure it out yourself that's pretty
much was an elephant Flight Credit and
an offering they're not even offering to
see if they can switch it themselves
they're not even looking they're just
like we can't do anything figure it out
now Southwest canceled more flights over
today and yesterday than any other
airline in the U.S their website says
Flyers traveling through January 2nd
they can rebook their original class
within 14 days of the original flight
that's without paying additional charges
but Travelers say that's not enough and
the big concern now is how is this going
to impact New Year's Eve travel we just
found out we're going to have hundreds
of thousands of people here for the
celebrations at this point it seems more
like a waiting game reporting live at
Harry Reid International of Ryan Matthey
a news now Ryan thank you very much so
if you are impacted by these disruptions
with Southwest or any other flights what
can you do Candace Charles live in The
Newsroom this afternoon with advice from
Passenger rights Advocates Candace
John according to the U.S Department of
Transportation you are entitled to a
refund because of cancellation or
significant delays if you choose not to
travel so that's for folks who are here
and maybe want to go somewhere else for
New Year's Eve if you stay put even with
that though kind of what constitutes a
significant delay remains left up to the
Airlines and if you do travel check your
amwelling's customer service plan if you
are impacted by Southwest there is a
customer service plan that says they
will only give flight or Mill vouchers
for cancellations that are within their
control whether is not the plan also
says that you not offer hotel vouchers
but will seek to arrange a discounted
hotel but Travel Experts say advocate
for yourself as soon as you know about
your cancellation or delay go to the
airline agent's desk call up the airline
while your weight you may get through to
the call center quicker know what you
want whether that's a hotel or food
voucher or to be put on another
airline's flight um unfortunately
Southwest does not partner with other
airlines but Delta American and a few
others do passenger rights Advocates ask
that you asked for any and all things
nicely
the airlines now have a dashboard which
has been set up by Dot and it will show
people what they can and they can't ask
for
now do your research remember each
airline has its own policies about
delays and cancellations there are no
federal requirements but you can file a
complaint with the U.S department of
transportation we have that link on our
website ennewsnow.com in The Newsroom
I'm Candace Charles 8 News Now can